hey guys welcome to ij likes i'm justine
and
here's an intro
so if you guys are new here which most
of you are not and if you're not new say
you're not new in the comments but if
you are ij likes is a show where i talk
about things that i like things that you
guys like that you send me to like and
we talk about it that's basically it
first up some videos that i liked this
week i saw this video and i'm not really
a very sentimental person but i thought
this was really freaking sweet during a
live peter pan performance peter pan
proposes to wendy
will you marry me
spoiler alert she says yes
one of my most searched things on
youtube is cute animals and when i came
across this sleepy little puppy i about
lost my mind if you think i cried during
peter pan and wendy this video i cried
with cuteness no
wake up
i love conan o'brien and i love gopro so
i was like oh i definitely have to see
this video click it's waste of a gopro
like conan says in the video normally
when you see gopro videos you expect to
see crazy sports and all these amazing
things well conan puts it on useless
things a gopro at the bottom of my
coffee mug okay i think that's a
complete waste of a gopro let's check it
out right now
which is pretty much what i do with my
gopro i don't really do any crazy sports
but i definitely like to vlog with my
gopro all right guys i'm going to put my
gopro on this carousel but i'm not going
to follow it so let's steal it okay
ready here we go
okay let's follow it
next up we have gaming and technology
which is appropriate because the past
week we had the biggest week of
technology which is ces i've been to ces
i think maybe five six years i think
i've lost count but it's one of the most
amazing events ever it's pretty much
this entire huge convention floor filled
with electronics
there's so much stuff going on we can't
ever find our way anywhere on press day
i was super excited because i got to go
up on stage with intel and do a demo of
the real sense 3d and after i did the
keynote demo i got to do a demo myself
and really play with it and see what
it's all about it's kind of cool because
i absolutely love games and i love
shooting videos on my computer because
it's always so much easier and when i
first started doing all this youtube
stuff i basically shot everything on my
eyesight so with this real sense 3d
technology this simple small camera can
be integrated into laptops tablets i'd
like one on my phone but the cool thing
about it is it uses 3d so if i'm
reaching forward for you the camera will
sense that so for example if you'll see
here i was trying to juggle these balls
but i was too far away so i just had to
reach up and juggle one of the cool
things for us vloggers is i've
i hate doing green screen because i hate
keying out my background but with the
realsense 3d it will sense the depth and
remove the background automatically i
need this now i was joking that my plan
is i'm going to take a picture of my
room when it's really clean and even if
it's a mess i'll just put the clean
background on my videos and no one will
even know that i'm a slob you want to
check out some more of my ces videos
i'll put a link in the description and
also an annotation somewhere around here
if i don't forget next up is ij book
club guys i
have been obsessed with audible like i
know i always mention it and i talk
about it but in december i listened to
56.46 hours if you guys want to get a
free audible book in a 30 day free trial
use the link below it's audible.com
ijustine and you can join the ij book
club because honestly i've been having
so much fun in december i listened to
all three hunger games books divergent
insurgent and now i'm on allegiant right
now i'm not exactly as into that book as
the other two my entire family was
getting so annoyed because i'd be like
eating dinner and i'd be like putting my
iphone here trying to listen while
everybody else is talking and i'm just
like
like stop it we get it we get it you
like to listen to audiobooks so let me
know what book you think i should listen
to next and we can all discuss in the
next episode of ij likes don't forget
link in the description if you want to
get your free audiobook and now we're
moving on to style and beauty which i
apologize i have absolutely
nothing
for this segment
at all closest i can come to a beauty
product that i can suggest is a really
nice
mario chapstick uh really fashionable
today with a black tank top
thank you guys so much for watching this
episode of ij likes as always be sure to
send me things that you think that i
might like for future episodes got a
bunch of fun videos coming up stay tuned
for a new swatch watch video it's like
my most favorite thing to do it's not
for bigfoot so i hope you guys enjoy
those i hope you guys enjoy these videos
i don't even know let me know in the
comments below what you guys want to see
some things that you like
i think i asked you to leave a comment
about something else but i don't
remember what it was so
yeah see you guys later bye
you